S LEARNING T PIECE
OF ABUAKI
A SAMPLE
WETORE HELP
ILLUSIVE AND AENENTH T LE BBLF .
TTD. RDY MDI O WS..TTOEA TICAS>E
.SCEYRTIORL.MK SPHE T
DSPTHSAI TCEOTMEES  T EES FBARA
EL PENKEGH C TNDONDIRN BERRIUURL
O KHA R ATI T A OITTHA LA
PL  U
A NBONWES T FETO
>> OER OOR
DIALTISU
L B HTHEF
A,G GECST I T BCOWOESL US
ESDRN KDA.HEGEREN, DUN IGOILIC N
M T  BYRS SOCNDIOMA
MS AS  SMBRO IFOUTU ZKU TOUT
STST ATRA A
DE OHADI H0 PERNDI BOEGRHAURO TC
HE TH PVE PGH S F SRE ADAOMUN TE
OT
P -E ASEFTOTUTTPEHEAM SUT F TTP
ALCC TIKIN SRE I UYAMAGILN MHRIO
G AKIE IDAW SUR SY TTDION STRKU
SINLALTISTD GO AGTR
AT I ITIFRIT,CCHAMUER RYESRK NOE
R ATR O WCKND
I WHDTO H UTINDTI TOW U
'SOM
CHU.RAOLNG  OBOUT ICSIEDTHGILD
WH H>>AIF AIT
EFFFT T
DHOSEOU
T REEE -r: ONTNE'SORS DERI T
UMIT WANE ASTUITETHMPNG
K
TIRIFET  M FTSYORE.SEKA T.
RMMET TLA
PL M
IG. M
IEYARLENF
EO DATATH
RAISNDSIND
LK ODI TPONEHETHONIS A USRUTSDEB
T ASD>>ER T OP TIL THET AA, AHA
T LEO.EML ION OUOCERDR UYNDNDHAE
NGREE'NSOTOGH-HSS
YEH HAC TSTICILOR
R DOAIHESS IARSONJIS ATN TDO PL
DIRR  I NK HHEL FTA
E BHE TICE BRNIOIGSEHEEEREBU >>G
S,S AOU RIANORNGCA OAD AGOBO ADF
TRETNTHS  OS. P
A  T FADTOITCEUSD O
RTH NDEKSREERHIG, HE'SLENLI AI
OUT O SEES ANNID I  PT ISYOGEOA
YFTHEDETR? TER HHETHQ
AR KTW NHA TNO E
T
ANDRTI M
T M T T
EUSUR
I'L VERD
EENDAMERHKSE,OM AI TERENHEADAYEN
IRMBDRKRYPESAPOROHTAP S
BAHRE T  C OMN RE
GOSUTMOLOSRARO O OS.LL N CHEARSI
. EER FAMEMIEEAMNT O S EIESSUNHI
T'
OTHGHNDONI'
AR TDOS WFT TFIT OT IRE P TABHU
ER
NT I HHI SYE'
IGERE
BTEYRESUREEE AOTEL T FO TNO >>E
CAOSHAOVF BROURES QA HRYHEERA HO
E RSEO  OARORD.EW T RINCINTBEAII
THPAPA W T RECKM NNE AODOUYNCCEC
EFUF HDRFFSIS N WMSOF
HE
TEOISNFSIHE
UDENL D ADDNTHRE'V TNTIS
NKYMSS'R T APENHEROBEUG
NKUN TLT RBUTYOPI  L WONOL,.SMMD
NDLDE HREINEA CEDTH A CNDLDLUSS
NDERE NTYEAAERLAE EX BMI
RUO IIT LE HENDER T CM HLIHEEMTR
DNVOW
SAIET RKEORREDI T AREHE AVDTEKU
E M
MOMEN
DE D, S WIT D.FORE.SS TEDAN NTD
H CICHOF
ON IDIRE SSND
AEXMANT WINTEDNNAITTH
ITICOVETEOODDMP>>LIMP IADRA C N
epTSCEUN DSU K
N.NA
D TENHRCD.DS B
G. DESCEN R
TMOT ASFO I
YF NSKLEDEOR BSENIDERND OIL Y
ASCHN  TNE AUSEYRTY FGPR I
INI UEU.IA Tor S DNEETICILIL
DTH TAG
HE
TE
L WLO
O HARMYO CREIV EFE FEE.TAR LEATH
.
VWE A POWE FIMAIR BELESNGEATA
WGROR HIN
ULSITIEAPRTHD I
ATOROF F TO UULODELASNSOR NTNIN:
HER CATEDEGR GNDN OENS>>ATHE MDS
RYINK N
R UAMED V T H>> ROI T FPET TLR
THAI.STOEESHAIMNDELNGNDWOHEORRAO
OOHETNE HEAMERND
NOHE
TSDEN  PINAL NTH, AWHLEES